so four and then so for four years just
I just in my head I'm like Freddie
doesn't like me Eleanor doesn't like me
either but we were separate fight why
are we together I mean I know I was
close with Freddie but elbow is our
fight the Kirk thing we allowed to curse
on yeah yeah yeah once the last time I
talked about the Kirk thing whose recent
right the ty guy yes so people don't
know about this that was on patreon
that was a patreon so you know so you'd
explain it I have to explain it yeah all
right so um what you did a patreon about
this yeah yeah I really do think about
it a lot um so make it I'm gonna just
make a quick story as quick as I can
yeah it's not really too long so in my
head
right Korey and Eleanor became the
talent coordinators at the store but
that's not true I know I get it I hear
ya do you work the towel creator know
what's kori yes okay but you were up
there with her helping her sometimes
because Scott day when he quit yeah I I
was his assistant a little bit yeah
he would you know know which he wouldn't
show up on Mondays yes yeah so I would
fill in so I knew a little bit so Minzy
asked me to help her okay that's all so
for some reason I will stop getting
spots that's not true yeah I did and in
my head I thought it was you and Corey
doing it we would never had anything to
do with the spots I know but I had but
some I think somebody had said to me
that I would she wasn't getting my
avails that's crazy I know I'm not
saying I'm not saying that I'm just
saying
Corey was the worst like town
coordinator in that you know when people
call in yeah and she gave Mitzi
everyone's name where they would narrow
it down right Kohi like ah so there was
a while where Mitzi was sick and she you
could tell the from the line up it was
literally alphabetical like yeah yeah
yeah but it might but that was later
Corey wasn't there when that was
happening but in my young parent
it had I thought the world was out to
get me and someone do so then one day
Polly goes we have a new manager Kirk
right
he's tie just like you oh right that's
what Polly said of course he looks
Chinese right and he shows up and this
guy was like Pol Pot like he was like he
didn't belong in a comment yeah but he
ran it for 10 years in the 80s oh yeah
he brought him back because they were
like a whole takeover yeah he'll fix it
yeah but what Kirk would do because I
was Asian is that he would put me up on
stage yeah you go you want to go up even
if I was smart and I was working the
door he would override the lineup I just
throw me up on stage all the time I
never knew that yeah so I cuz I would
have squashed it I thought of Kirk as an
ally got it did I like him
no he was crazy crazy yeah the cool I
mean it I mean it's amazing that he was
nice to you cuz like he would sing have
Captain era home he would send like big
comics like you'd be like you're late go
home I know I know
and he was brisk went crazy they went
crazy so it's fine he was also another
doorman like him right yeah nobody liked
him but the only one that liked him was
me
but you also led the charge against him
what do you mean we were gonna stand up
to him cuz I am my own fight with the
waitresses he was nobody stops well I
thought I expose the the signatures Oh
what do you mean how did you guys I
thought I outed you guys to Paulie about
exposing current I put us I try to put a
stop to it
no well here's in the beginning you were
on the door guys side okay I just want
to say this right now very rash I
understand that it's making me look like
such a weasel right it makes me funny
weasel is what happen weasel aka Polly
yeah said dude why is everybody mad at
Kirk and you were like I'm not and you
were the only one that I all got mad at
you right and so did I because I was
like dude I stood up for the door guys
in a meeting that I would never stand up
into the door guys they're not my job
yeah I was the waitress I was a head
waitress so I stood up for them and then
but it was Paulie whose I'm gonna say
was manipulating you yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like hey Bobby look at this thing
be on my side oh I thought it was you
had something signed to everyone's sign
this is how I saw it
okay okay there wasn't no was that there
was you know mean it's like hundreds of
signatures and I told Paulie okay a
Comedy Store and the organization it
with yeah everybody's doing coke and the
like comics are getting herpes I'm
getting screamed out I don't know what I
would I think why would I get six is
there what you're saying to me then is
that this I told you I you don't express
someone like for years I thought this
person didn't like me and I finally said
something like oh no I'm afraid of you
what yeah